speaking of passers one of the great
passers in college basketball history
Doug Gottlieb joins us on loan from Fox
Sports Doug how are you today good can I
tell my quick Jason Kissinger to two
stories actually he and Kevin ollie were
in the same backcourt on au team before
his senior year and like you know my dad
was a former college coach had his own
AAU program one of great games ever saw
into Vegas North Jim
remember those gyms we used to go watch
you and I'll be practicing that used to
be the spot for the big AAU national
championship which occurred every July
anyway my dad's team had rigid gear he
was his point but I went to Arizona
anyway they they they lost by one Jason
Kidd hit the game-winner that was the
first time I saw him play and he was
just he was just like he's the fastest
point guard I can remember he had great
end to end speed the next time I saw him
was against modern day his his final
game his senior year
st. Joseph's Alameda and he was so
incredibly dominant like modern day had
like 10 first man Division 1 guys and he
completely dominated the game the last
play of his high school career was a
breakaway dunk he dunked the ball they
called timeout to come out of the game
and everybody in Arco Arena stood up and
give him a standing ovation even modern
day fans he's to me he maybe gets
disrespect in terms of where he stands
all-time but him Steve Nash I think you
kind of forgot in terms of past first
guys creating shots and other people is
a gift that so few people have I wanted
to have you on I wanted to get your
thoughts on this you're plugged into
college basketball obviously but with
what Lavar ball has presented here the
concept of what he's doing if if
somebody else presented this would we
look at this and take it more seriously
than the fact that Lavar ball is
presenting the come out of high school
I'm going to create my own league no
remember there was actually one of my
former teammates Glenn and Alexander
tried this exact same thing and only he
was doing it under an alias and they
found out that it was under an alias mer
this is a couple you like two years ago
supposed to be in Las Vegas pay guys 100
grand
look the problem is he says well we've
been thinking about this for a couple
months like okay well the plan doesn't
make any sense
80 guys for 10 teams that's eight guys a
team like you can say this is not an au
rec league dude you can't have eight
guys on a team like that doesn't work
you know got one guy doesn't show up one
guy gets hurt one guy's sick you got
five guys on a bench and you're gonna
play a forty-eight minute game like just
the the whole concept like his whole
idea is so it I mean it's it's just kind
of slapped together so if it was
somebody else
ya know I don't I don't really think so
look here's here's here's something that
I don't think people understand you know
you can go to the G League yeah right
out of high school yeah you don't have
to go to you don't have to go to college
nobody forces you forget about overseas
you can go and they've increased the
salary somewhat but you can go play in
front of NBA scouts play with NBA
caliber professional coaches playing
great facilities practice at times
against NBA teams nobody does it because
college basketball is a great
promotional tool and it's a great
developmental tool and it provides you
the fallback so I'm this concept has
been thrown around the past and the fact
that that Lavar is throwing it out was
such a such a bad plan like we're gonna
play in NBA arenas like do you
understand how much that cost and how
that has to work and he has no bit he
has no business acumen at all to think a
plan that was well thought out but is
this just that he loves staying in the
news cycle and it's a way to stay in the
news cycle do you think that he really
is committed to somehow trying to make
this work while his kids are playing in
Lithuania well I think he's I think he's
committed I think there is a thirst for
this from a lot of people but you know
it's like didn't is in the XSL maybe
going to come back like there have been
people people that there's been plenty
of players and agents and and current
players like ban even in even Lonzo last
night after the game which they took
down the rocket said you know I I
probably would have done this instead of
going to college which is ridiculous
because playing at UCLA allowed him to
elevate his profile to where he was
number to pick and oh yeah by the way
when everything is done he'll be able to
go back and get a UCLA degree so
I look I think that that there are there
are plenty of people especially on
social media and there are people in the
media that thinks somehow the college
system is bad and somehow it uses kids
when the opposite is actually true and
there is a thirst for this sort of thing
but it's going to fail much like the XFL
is failed much like the CBA failed the
only reason the G League exists and has
been relatively successful has been
they've massively cut cost and it's
subsidized by the by the NBA if not it
would fail like other minor leagues but
like I play minor league basketball I
played in the u.s. BL but in the IBA I
made a CBA team only to get cut because
Randy Livingston got cut in the NBA I
got beat out 13 dudes made the team and
then the day before the first game got
cut because Randy Livingston got cut and
he came down to the CB I play noticed
like minor league basketball sucks you
might be getting a paycheck you might
not and the idea that and you might be
playing in front of 50 people and the
idea that that's a better setup for a
high school kid than going to a college
program playing for a coach that's
worked with kids of that age for 25 to
30 years is a joke and everybody who
says otherwise is completely obtuse to
reality Doug good to check in with you
we appreciate that thanks for joining us
as always hey how much fun is Trey young
to watch play a lot of fun I just as I'm
texting Doug during that game I just I
loved his form and then all of a sudden
I realized that he's putting up some big
numbers his sister wise ended up with
with 22 so it it's good it's fun fun to
see a guy's bomb like that a little bit
and also past no no he can he can he can
really play you know yeah by the way
that's college basketball smoting a kid
who most most of America had never heard
of and everybody was tweeting about and
I you're gonna pay attention when
Oklahoma plays basketball
thank you Doug that's a Doug Gottlieb
yeah Trey young at Oklahoma leading the
nation in scoring and assists a lot of
fun see what happens when he gets into
conference play or goes against some of
these bigger guards or longer players
but love what I what I got to see for
more Dan Patrick show
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]